The environment gets the shaft for sure, but
now studies are starting to show that if one
person start composting, their neighbors will
too… it’s like… an environmentalism
arms race!
Environmentalism isn’t sexy.
We know from other DNews videos that if I
say "Global Warming" some of you will perk
up but if I say, "Climate Change," you are
out of here faster than radiation through
an o-zone hole…
BOOM, Now you’re back!
"Environmentalist arms-race" has that same
effect, I bet.
Humans evolved to pay attention to things
that affect THEM and climate change is EXTREMELY
difficult to get people to pay attention to
simply because it’s so huge.
But there is one way to get everyone to pay
attention, buy something flashy that shows
you care more than they do.
Think about it!
When people buy things to show off their status,
like a Louis Vuitton bag, the latest game
console for their house, diamonds for their
ears, necks, or hands, or latest mobile phone
to flash around… that’s called Conspicuous
Consumption.
It’s a psychological term coined by an economist
in the early 20th century.
We WANT people to think we’re classy, and
we’ll buy things to show off our social
class.
Conspicuous consumption is tied to another
American idiom: "keeping up with the Joneses."
The idea being, we don’t want to be left
behind in our social group.
It’s an evolutionary tactic, chimps groom
and make things, they show off and compete.
It’s a normal part of primate life.
The thing is, studies from Cal Berkeley, Universities
of Minnesota and New Mexico and countries
around the world show there’s also an environmentalist
version of this: Conspicuous Conservation.
This is where people gain status in their
social groups by being MORE environmentally
conscious.
They buy a hybrid in a land of Hummers, start
recycling in a place where people send everything
to a landfill…
It’s the green version of buying a designer
suit, and they’re not mutually exclusive,
they’re inexorably connected.
Many brands know this now too, and design
their environmentally friendly products to
fit with conspicuous consumption psychology.
A study from Cal Berkeley in 2012 found that
the design of the Prius affects its sales.
The Prius is the most successful hybrid, in
terms of sales, in part because it LOOKS like
a hybrid, they found.
People want you to KNOW you’re environmentally
conscious, it’s a status symbol.
A study in American Psychologist looked at
emotional behaviors around environmentalism,
and its pretty easy for us to get swept into
smaller things like recycling plastic bottles,
but denial of environmental problems — like
climate change — will overwhelm any beneficial
impacts.
Psychologists are working to discover more
ways to help people feel good about helping
the Earth, but the question is, even though
we know this is part of our evolution as a
social species, and part of a group mentality,
are we actually helping the environment??
Some argue that this is just conspicuous consumption
under a different name, which doesn’t help
anything; while others argue that buying greener
products is good, regardless of motivation.
But what do you think?
If we end up making the world better in order
to keep up with the Joneses is that as good
as making it better because we wanted to in
the first place?